how do I introduce this guy live from
Houston it's Wednesday afternoon he is
fresh off his fantastic SNL hosting
appearance he is a perennial Pro Bowler
future hall-of-famer JJ Watt here on the
show how are you JJ rich I'm good I want
to say that was a beautiful segue Thank
You Brady brothers over to me so that
was great you know what JJ I just have
just got to bring my a-game with you as
a matter of fact I will describe to you
what I'm doing I am removing my rich
eyes and show coffee mug here and I am
replacing it in honor of you calling in
with you on one side of a mug
celebrating what appears to be a sack
from the Wisconsin days and the final
score of this year's Wisconsin Michigan
game it's saying this cup holds rich
aizen's tears so I'm doing that what my
beautiful mug just well designed just
glad to see it on the air I appreciate
that thank you
you know what JJ it's just it's just an
unfortunate development but it is one
that I own and it's also proof that
you've got the comedy chops that's why
you got the call from SNL that's why you
got that call they did yeah I appreciate
that I appreciate that when did you
first get that call from from NBC a
couple weeks back and I mean it was I
mean it's SNL it's such an exciting
iconic show and I grew up in Wisconsin
and Chris Farley and just some of his
bits and skits and I mean Matt Foley the
motivational speaker and just just
legendary stuff and so for me to be able
to go there and to see everything and
they showed me some of the old Farley
stuff and some little he had written
something on a wall there that they
showed men it was just it was a really
really cool experience can you repeat
what he wrote on a wall or that just has
to stay he know here there they showed
me that so when you're doing the show
you are literally sprinting from place
to place like quick changes and yeah
dress changes and all that
there's one area where if you don't duck
if you're over 6 feet tall and you don't
duck you will absolutely rock your
forehead and they said that Farley used
to hit it over and over and over again
because he just he would be you're
sprinting it didn't know so they put
like this big pad with like bright
colors on everything and he wrote on
there for far away this because it was
for him specifically and so they showed
me that and it was really cool and it
probably helped you with all that I mean
again we're strolling we're scrolling
through some stills from your appearance
you made many changes many wigs there
seemed to be some some makeup involved
as well I mean walk me through
incredible dad yeah so so obviously
during the week you get fitted for wigs
all of all your wigs they make basically
a full mold of your head and then they
built the wigs off of that mold and then
they for me for the Bigfoot sketch but
they actually put prosthetics on my face
right he's going and you get a full mold
of your face made kind of like when you
get a teeth mold it's a dentist when
they put that stuff in your mouth yeah
to form against your teeth they do that
but with your whole face when they build
that during the show it truly is crazy
you're like I said you're sprinting from
place to place and as soon as you get to
a quick-change location you just put
your arms out put your legs out and
there are three people just ripping
clothes off of you throwing new clothes
on you rip wigs are flying it's it's
insane so I imagine though JJ Watt here
on the Rich Eisen show I imagine though
the toughest thing for you was that
monologue what I would that be the
safest assumption or or what to get out
there and just say as far as the writing
of it goes that was definitely something
that we spent a lot of time on just
because for me I wanted it to be as much
in my voice in in my comfort level as I
felt we could make it and so obviously
early in the week they don't know me
that well I don't know that well we're
trying to write something funny and good
together without knowing each other that
well and then as the week goes on if you
saw the monologue from Wednesday and
then you saw what
was on Saturday night and they don't
look even recognizable to each other and
so I think that was my biggest thing as
I always said even if the monologue
flops or doesn't do good or anything I
at least want to feel comfortable with
it have it be in my voice and I feel
like we got through a really good place
on Saturday night with and I was very
happy with well during Super Bowl week I
had Deion Sanders on on my show down in
Miami and I asked him what advice would
you give JJ Watt for hosting Saturday
Night Live because you know he did it he
did it way back in the day and and he
said to that that you're gonna have a
lot of ideas pitched at you and you've
got to be comfortable with the ones that
you do which was the one that you were
most I guess comfortable doing I have
all the ideas that we actually saw on
television JJ the one the one that I
immediately when they pitched it on I
think it was Tuesday that I knew it was
gonna be gold was the Rudy skit Robbie
Rudy I mean I grew up watching Rudy as
one of my favorite movies of all time I
loved it iconic and then when they
pitched it and we just started flowing
with the jokes and we start going
through what the dialogue could look
like in the janitor and the five foot
nothing on dress it was just I was like
this is gonna be golden well I mean and
the best part about it is again you're
you're the guy that refuses to let the
coach use the under sized guys
inspiration you're just standing there
pointing out we cannot go on the field
with this guy actors are so funny in
Keenan whenever he says anything is
hilarious
it was so much fun and so what did you
say I just can't do can you tell me what
wound up on the cutting room floor
JJ um there really wasn't a ton so like
the interesting part about is say
cutting room floor so on Wednesday you
read through 45 scripts and they've they
45 full scripts you do a full table read
through with the whole cast and
everybody in the room right and then you
chop that down to 11 and then you take
11 to the full dress rehearsal on
Saturday night two hours before the
actual show and then after that so in
you have an hour and
between the dress rehearsal on the
actual show you cut that 11 down to like
eight so it's just it is truly wild how
much happens and what goes on so like
one that got cut that that we cut right
after the dresser before the show was it
was just I'm in like a cabaret bar and I
ended up on the stage singing they
probably cut it because of my absolutely
horrendous vocals which thankfully
nobody had to hear that besides and the
frozen skin when I am I saying a little
bit the whole process is truly
incredible how quickly they turn things
around how quickly and calmly they make
decisions and no amount of time it's
unbelievable and then they got to do it
again I mean it's kind of I mean in a
way like that's like a foot it's a grind
of a football season right it's it's
it's one it's a one-week preparation for
a New York case three and three and
three hours maybe three and a half for
them with it I guess with a dress
rehearsal it it's like three hours and
then and you just okay that's done let's
do it again it's unbelievable
it's it's so similar and it's really
impressive so and it all builds up just
like you said you start on Monday and
you build up to prepare you right you
know you read your scripts just like
sudden your playbook and then you're
building up towards one live event with
a real audience with pressure on the
line with having to make changes and
having to get your lines and there's all
these people you know hundreds of people
backstage yes shifting sets and moving
stuff it's literally if one person
screws up it screws up the whole team
just like sports and I was talking like
some of the guys behind the scenes and
they were like we've we've been doing
this for twenty plus years and the
adrenalin that you get on Saturday night
reminds me of when I played high school
football or when I played you know so
it's it's very similar in that aspect
where you're part of a team and you get
the adrenaline rush and there really
aren't many places you can get that JJ
Watt here on the Rich Eisen show and
then when it's all over this one I've
been to I've been with an SNL afterparty
I mean it's in Santa think oh that can
go all night so did you hit did you hit
that too and like stay out three four in
the morning that's
the thing you hit that absolutely III
told myself when I booked it I was like
listen I'm gonna do it right I'm gonna
I'm gonna do everything I'm gonna let it
loose and I'm gonna do the after party
and I have not stayed up until I think
we got back to my hotel room like 5:30
a.m. yeah I have not stayed up that late
in long long time but well well worth it
as you know like you said you've been to
one it's just the fun you have the
stories that are going around it's just
it's a blast and then there's others who
weren't I guess part of the broadcast
show up did anybody you got any names
that people that just showed up
and hung out I'm not a big name dropper
real so I mean I already dropped your
name to get the gay guy JJ that's that's
next level right there I appreciate that
I just wanna I just want to get in the
behind the velvet ropes with you JJ
that's all you know just trying to get
that yeah I mean yeah but you got to get
behind it over good and then did you I
guess
recuperating time to watch the Superbowl
did you take that game in Oh JJ so I
flew back to Houston on Sunday so I was
flying during pretty much the first half
so I got back to my house sometime in
the second half and I caught
I caught the ending of it caught the
fourth quarter so I got to see that so
what do you think of the narrative that
the Niners should I run more well I
guess you're probably hearing all the
all the the second guessing of it what
did you think of the ending and somebody
who's been on if you will the wrong end
of a Holmes run or in a way knowing how
a Nevin flow of a game just works out
the way it just works out I wonder what
your two cents in the subject are I mean
I have always had this view you know as
an athlete and as you play stuff it's it
is so easy to say what you should have
done or even when you're sitting at home
watching a game as it's happening what
you should do in this situation how a
team should play it the services is
nobody's out there unless you've unless
you're a former coach or a former player
who's been in that situation in that
environment with that level of pressure
on you and everything I don't think
anybody can sit here and say what you
would have done what you wouldn't done
or how you should have played it
I'm sure they're doing that in their
heads as they sit now a couple days
later I mean just like we did with our
game a few weeks ago you know you sit
there next couple days you look at what
should we have done different how could
we have done what should and even then
you don't have the answers I mean yeah
should they have not given up points and
should they have scored points
absolutely but I mean it's much I wish
it broke down like that you know and
then the last one for you I thought of
you at honors night when it saw Elias
Campbell get up there the big man he's
gonna have that patch on his chest now
like you have a Walter Payton Man of the
Year what's going on with you and your
your works down there in Houston that we
can know about get involved in all that
good stuff what do you got uh uh first I
want to say congrats to clay a Texan
that night he is truly deserving he's
one of the great guys in the game and I
love the way he plays I love his
attitude I love seeing him every time
whether it's in the offseason after the
game he has such a big smile he's just
such a great human being and a great guy
so I'm very excited and honored to
welcome into that fraternity because he
truly does deserve it with me the
foundation is still talking along I
believe in the last month you know we
just we give people updates as we go on
on our Twitter page on how we're
distributing the money and I think in
the month of January we donated like one
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
to schools throughout the country and we
just keep going quarter by quarter and
trying to help as many kids as we can
across the country either man JJ happy
fight when I reached out to you when I
heard you got SNL I mean that is a
that's his I mean that's the pinnacle
brother I mean that is when you're your
sports star and you're an athlete and
you want to just have some fun and SNL
reaches out to you that's that's it I
mean that's amazing and you crushed it
so congrats thank you thank you my
friend I appreciate you having me on and
I hope you guys have a wonderful day
okay so I can put this mug away now can
I just put it back what do you think
yeah until the next time I need a big
gig or you got it JJ it'll be right here
I'll be right here it'll be right here
in the old mothballs hopefully for a
long time take care yourself later my
friend you got it right back at you
that's JJ Watt for more
Jason showtune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app